bonjour à jean-marc bienvenue dans
bienvenue dans cette matinale berthet
france alors ses prix descendent sous la
halle évidemment de questions d'abord
pourquoi ces nouvelles hausses et
ensuite que peut-on faire que peut faire
le gouvernement pour calmer les prix
question difficile et évidemment les
prix de carburants sont effectivement à
nouveau
envolé à cette semaine bercy nous a
confirmé que jamais les prix à la pompe
avec aussi cher le gazole a dépassé en
moyenne 1 63 euro lui le litre c'est le
moyen là mais on tourne autour de 1 63
l'essence sans plomb est monté à plus de
1 75 euro je crois qu'il faut remonter à
2018 pour avoir un prix aussi élevé ça
fait des pleins moyens qui oscille entre
50 et 80 euros selon les voitures mais
pour beaucoup de familles ces deux à
nouveau insupportable alors s'est envolé
à a surpris tout le monde parce que la
dernière hausse en décembre c'était un
peu effacé au moment de noël
progressivement et on croyait être
revenu à une situation plus normale
et alors là c'est reparti est reparti
avec violence vous avez en gros 3 3
bonnes raisons que trois bonnes raisons
sus pas si elles sont bonnes mais mais
mais elles sont réelles dans tous les
cas et qu'on connaît le prix du
carburant ça dépend de l'offre et de la
demande alors l'activité économique qui
s'était passé un peu avec la quatrième
vague du variant au micron quand on a vu
cette va y arriver bien on a re révisé à
la baisse un certain nombre
d'investissements d'activité donc la
demande s'était ralentie et puis alors
tout est reparti avec le recul du
variant et ça dans le monde entier juste
après la vive 7 et on voit le résultat
aujourd'hui la deuxième raison c'est que
vous avez des pays producteurs qui
spéculent un peu actuellement mais vous
avez aussi des régions pétrolières qui
sont un peu bousculée avec des risques
géopolitiques or on l'a vu les robinets
sont menacés
la frontière cren la russie l'arabie
saoudite et le yémen sur tout mais la
sécurité n'est pas assurée on pas enfin
il fait froid
on est l'hiver donc on consomme beaucoup
plus d'énergie et puis vous avez
certains pays producteurs c'est le
canada on le disait tout à l'heure dans
votre reportage qui ont du mal à
maintenir le niveau de production chez
les champs pétroliers sont quand même
pris dans la glace alors tout ça
déséquilibre le marché international et
tous ces facteurs font monter le prix du
brut le brut est à 85 dollars le baril
il pourrait s est joint 19 espère
continuer une remontée aux alentours de
4 h 10 certainement la banque américaine
goldman sachs ont la cité ya un instant
c'est vrai voile dollars à voile le brut
à asson dollars c'est pas parce que tu
jamais vu alors que peut faire le
gouvernement concrètement et écouter le
gouvernement sur ces facteurs
géopolitiques ne peut pas grand chose il
peut pas toucher les robinets de
l'arabie saoudite ou des autres pays
producteurs alors il ne peut pas faire
autre chose que ce qu'il a déjà fait
c'est à dire colmater les brèches le
gouvernement pourrait évidemment réduire
les taxes sur les carburants parce que
dans 1 litre d'essence on fait quand
même plus de la moitié en taxes mais
franchement réduire les taxes sur
l'essence serait suicidaire pour le
budget le gouvernement perdrait une
grande partie de ses recettes fiscales
qui sont là beaucoup plus importante que
l'impôt sur le revenu il faut le savoir
alors le gouvernement peut toujours
soulager la facture en distribuant de
l'argent l'échec car durant les chèques
énergie tinée prémat l'électricité mais
ça ça coûte un prix exorbitant et ça
n'empêche pas le prix du brut de monter
on a vient d'ailleurs d'envoyer la le
nouveau chèque de 100 euros ça disparaît
assez rapidement en 2021 on a dû
craindre et près de 30 milliards d'euros
30 milliards d'euros pour calmer la
grogne des automobilistes
on va sans doute continuer pourquoi pas
parce que on est en campagne
présidentielle et que le gouvernement a
forcément pas forcément intérêt à
remettre de l'huile sur le feu dans ce
débat alors il y aura une autre solution
une autre solution qui serait beaucoup
plus dur à à beaucoup plus structurelle
ce serait de dépenser cet argent pour
accélérer le passage à l'électrique
investir plus massivement qu'on le fait
encore dans les voitures les batteries
et les stations de recharge surtout
qu'ils sont très rares et c'est ça le
frein c'est qu'on a du mal à perdre j'ai
voitures électriques aujourd'hui donc
ça n'incite pas forcément à acheter une
voiture est aussi relancer la production
d'une électricité nucléaire mais on ne
voit pas dans les programmes
présidentiels l'affirmation d'une
ambition très forte les écologistes se
sont très frileux ils hésitent encore
beaucoup parce qu'ils savent que si on
passe au tout électrique eh bien il
faudra fabriquer de l'électricité est
donc relancé du nucléaire et ça c'est
pas très populaire surtout encore
présidentielle les gouvernements sur un
peu piéger les automobilistes aussi jean
marc est ce que cette remontée des prix
du carburant peut relancer l'inflation
généralisée
enfin c'est le débat c'est le risque
dont tous les économistes au raffolent
mais c'est un risque auquel on peut
difficilement croire à court terme les
hausses de prix sont très localisés très
segmenté les carburants le pétrole le
gaz l'électricité aussi parce que son
prix dépend du fuel et dépend du gaz
vous avez des produits alimentaires des
composants industriels qui sont bloqués
actuellement encore en asile il peut
briller un peu mais pour le reste bas
vous avez vous n'avez pas de
contamination aux autres produits et
surtout vous n'avez pas de contamination
fortes hausses salariales c'est peu de
hausses de salaires sauf dans les
secteurs en tension la restauration par
exemple en france ils ne trouvent pas à
embaucher ou dans le digital les
syndicats sont globalement ne sont pas
très vindicatif sur les salaires les
seules hausses de salaires vous le
disait son secteur avec des forte
productivité avec des forts déficits en
emploi le e-commerce le digital mais on
arrive en campagne présidentielle on
peut avoir un mouvement revendicatif à
la hausse un mouvement de rattrapage la
vdab sein de l'entreprise qui ont versé
d'importants dividendes et dont les
salariés peuvent se dire eh bien on a en
a droit quand même à cette part du
gâteau mais on ne voit pas un phénomène
de contagion en europe notamment
notamment aussi parce que l'équilibré
international géopolitique avec les
incertitudes qui pèsent sur la chine ne
ne participe pas à ce mouvement
inflationnistes les etats unis sont sans
doute plus menacé que nous mais ça
restera limitée l'économie est dominée
par la croissance aujourd'hui
par l'investissement par l'innovation
par l'emploi tous les indicateurs sont
assez bien orienté ouverts dont
l'économie génère du travail génère de
la richesse et ça ça ne pas
impressionner un peu d'optimisme
merci beaucoup aux jambes marc sylvestre
s'était l'édito échos de la matinale d
arte france